en este vídeo conectaremos los cables a
los motores usaré un cable azul para que
se distinga mejor es un cable de calibre
22 con núcleo sólido y uso el pelador de
cables para cortarlo y para sostenerlo
mientras corto estoy usando las pinzas
planas después jalo el aislamiento con
el pelador de cables y ahora en las
extremidades del cable formas un gancho
en ambas puntas del cable una punta irá
enganchada en la terminal restante de
nuestro interruptor de un polo y doble
tiro que es la terminal más cercana al
motor ahora con las pinzas de punta
plana puedes apretar el doblez que
hiciste en la punta del cable así
después tomas la otra punta del cable y
atraviesa lo vamos a atravesarlo en la
otra terminal del motor tienes ahí un
pequeño agujero de latón
por ahí atraviese el cable y ya que haya
atravesado formas también un doblez
asegúrate de que el cable tenga contacto
directo con el latón para que así haya
una mejor conexión y ya que están bien
colocadas las piezas las pegaremos con
silicón caliente
ahora hice lo mismo con el otro motor
pase el cable azul por la terminal en el
motor y también pase el cable azul por
el interruptor de un polo y doble tiro
lo que hice a un motor también se lo
hice al otro motor y sé exactamente la
misma conexión en ambos motores y ahora
nuevamente te recuerdo que es importante
que haya una buena conexión entre el
cable y el latón en el motor y ahora
revisa que los motores estén conectados
correctamente después vamos a usar este
cable blanco que es el cable de energía
a este cable le vamos a cortar un pedazo
pequeño del aislamiento
este es el cable del lado negativo de la
batería le quitamos un poco del
aislamiento
entonces ya que hicimos eso con este
cable vamos a examinar a los motores
veamos si están funcionando
adecuadamente
doble el cable para que toque los
motores y podrás escuchar el motor
entonces lo dobló hago que el cable
toque el latón y debes escuchar a los
motores girar
también el otro vamos a examinarlo
tocamos el latón con el cable y debe
escucharse así es como ve si están bien
conectados entonces ya nos queda claro
que los motores tienen un buen
funcionamiento ahora es bueno que estos
cables los dobles hacia arriba antes de
pegarlos con silicón porque una vez que
colocas el silicon sobre ellos y el
silicón enfría es muy difícil quitarlo
entonces si tú doblas los cables hacia
arriba habrá una conexión más sólida
entonces ya estamos listos para pegar
las conexiones y los motores con
silicona entonces vamos a colocar
silicon sobre las conexiones al hacerlo
asegúrate de que los cables se mantengan
en su posición para que así haya una
conexión sólida y se conduzca bien la
electricidad también puedes poner
silicón caliente sobre el clip que
sostiene los motores para que el clip se
mantenga en su lugar y de esa forma
también los motores por mucho pegamento
sobre la terminal y por mucho pegamento
para que los
no se muevan el pegamento también
funciona como aislamiento en nuestro
robot ahora puedes utilizar dos tapas de
botella para sostener arriba el robot y
que así los motores no toquen la
superficie de la mesa pues eso te va a
ayudar a que el silicón caliente enfríe
y los motores se mantengan en la
orientación correcta